[Music]
months after Hurricane Maria Puerto Rico
is still in peril huge swaths of the
island are still without power running
water or access to medical care experts
estimate that it would take years before
these services are restored island wide
much of the blame has been placed on
FEMA for a slow response in comparison
to recent disasters on the mainland but
recovery from a disaster of this
complexity and scale has proven more
challenging than anyone anticipated and
filling the gaps between an overextended
public sector and a suffering populace
falls on the private citizens
[Music]
Robert Anderson is a puerto rico
resident of four years the eye of the
storm came in south of el young Gabe
swept up toward San Juan and out the
Arecibo everything on the right hand
side is what we call the dirty vitamin
storm this isn't his first time in a
disaster zone with a military and
telecom background Anderson worked on
repairing damaged cellphone towers in
New Orleans after Hurricane Katrina some
might be tempted to label him a disaster
capitalists seeking lucrative government
contracts for his expertise but as
Anderson finds himself in the middle of
the humanitarian crisis he and his
associates are developing a variety of
pro bono recovery projects to target the
island's hardest hit areas I see two
Puerto Rico's we're here in San Juan
that telecommunications restored it may
or may not have power but basic services
are in place they're able to get food
they're able to buy things they're
surviving and when you look outside of
the San Juan area you can go 15 minutes
from here and find areas that are
devastated
I'm working on the devastated side today
he's put together a boots-on-the-ground
mission to provide medical care to some
of the islands most isolated and
vulnerable residents Steve Berenbaum is
one of Anderson's business associates he
offered an extra car and a set of hands
so we received an initial report from a
nurse that was out in the area were
headed to the northeast region of
Gujarat Oh for some people that are in
need of urgent medical assistance dr.
sally Priester as a physician from san
juan she filled a van with medical
supplies at her own expense and brought
along a team of nurses google maps
estimated our first destination to be a
90 minute drive
but it didn't account for obstacles like
this our first stop was the home of an
82 year old blind Vietnam veteran his
roof was blown off by the storm and he's
been living alone in a back shed for
nearly two months this cane actually got
broken in the storm so he's limited
mobility he has a number of medical
ailments dr. priest errs having a look
at him we called the VA they're gonna
get him set up with what he needs get
him stabilized so you can be transported
either to an evacuation center or off
the island it's when the chain gets
broken when those when those families
that are connected to them leave the
island or take off these guys get left
at the end of the road and it's tough
FEMA was not officially part of Roberts
team and their arrival caught everyone
by surprise their job here was to survey
and report back to their superiors and
did not come with medical aid of any
kind people think that FEMA is there to
hand out bottles of water it's not what
they do
FEMA has a role to play they have a very
specific role they bring in ships they
bring in airplanes they bring in tractor
trailers with pallets of things but
they're a big machine and there's gaps
in that thing and you're seeing one of
the gaps here and we help fill that role
these guys are a bad situation before
and now they're struggling for real
basic things one of the risks that
you're on is people going from fear to
hopelessness those are the folks that
we're trying to reach how are they
reached how are they even found word of
mouth mostly and what's your role in all
this ghost in the machine I'm lucky
enough to be able to communicate with
folks in FEMA the state of Puerto Rico
for a ghost Robert makes his presence
well known not only was he the de facto
leader of the mission now with FEMA and
tow he created his own maps to survey
storm damages and delivered them to FEMA
HQ free of charge I have a pretty good
reach
perhaps that's how he managed to earn
himself a coveted FEMA badge without
actually working for them and it's these
relationships that allow him to operate
more efficiently than an NGO or a
government agency we're able to resolve
problems at a different level our next
stop was on a mountaintop a family of 11
struggling to care for their special
needs brother in what was left of their
house probably we are the first helped
him to come and visit his family the
patient has Down syndrome he is all day
and dead the difficulty with this is the
patient cannot be alone the most
important thing is that you need to take
care of the chronic disease beside his
salary because they have been now going
to a doctor and now doctor has coming
here yet so we need a refill
after maybe 54 days it's not getting
better
in the only way that you can be able to
see that it's coming to the ground drive
and see the people and talk to the
people you can see San Juan from here
but you can't get there it's like the
Emerald City
on this stop we caught word that a man
living alone at the edge of the jungle
was in need of care so we decided take a
little detour come up here and check out
and see what's going on
one of challenges is to find those
people that are at the end of these
roads that need help they will get that
soil
I'm asking about blankies along right
here because they think so your life
happens yeah I'm here
kind of a
[Music]
this is not a job to do this you need to
have passion for what you can do you're
not going to get paid it's said in
disaster response an emergency response
that the real first responders are your
neighbors you don't need to wait for a
lucrative FEMA contract to go out and do
good and to help the community in the
end do you feel that you're making a
difference lives you touch the people
that you can affect I don't really think
about in those terms but why do you do
it it helps me sleep at night I think
it's as much for the people that are
going out to help and do things that is
for the people that you affect
whether out of altruism or the lure of a
paid gig or some mixture of the two
anderson hopes to stay here to help
shaped widow Rico's future puerto rico
has essentially been a colony for four
hundred years it was treated poorly by
the spanish was not treated well by the
united states when they first got here
puerto rico can continue in the way that
it's always been or puerto rico can
rebuild itself like nothing that's ever
been and we have to do everything we can
to make that real that's the bottom line
[Music]
you
you